Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tell us what's going on in Kashmir oh
it's very bad situation there for
Kashmiri brothers and sisters like you
know I just got news that about 13
thousand young boys were taken into
custody and Kashmir it's like that when
the army goes and picks up someone you
never hear from them you know the
families and they're going through hell
over there and the worst thing is they
can't communicate with anyone you know
because all lines have been shut for
them they don't have internet they don't
have telephone lines and and now there's
a blockade there so Kashmir is mainly
depend on tourism and agriculture and
agriculture like apples walnuts etc
they're not able to sell to anyone so
there's a lot of hunger there and the
situation is really bad seems like the
world is silent on us the world is
always silent when it comes to Muslims
you know it the world was silent and
Bosnian genocide happened the severn
Itza the world was silent
I was always silent for the Palestine
and the Syria and all that we know that
and if this is the right-wing government
now in India and he's best pants but you
know who Uncle Sam there was an event
and they you know greeted him there was
and the worst part is like Muslim
countries they are honoring him like
Saudi Arabia gave him the highest city's
civilian award UAE gave him the highest
civilian award and this guy you know
he's a butcher who's currently ruling
India I mean I think one of the things
we could do is create awareness uh-huh
yes that's one of the things we keep
keep them in the in
our doors and what else do you think we
advised um we are either Indians of
Pakistanis we are Arabs
we are not Muslims unfortunately when we
become come together as one as one OMA
and that is when I think the problems
would be solved and this is the same
thing that happens they will not
understand men are so misogynistic why
would even pick up with this why would
they look at the woman like in such a
such a manner but when you say although
one of us to do so that men pray in
front only pray in the back okay it's a
Paula very interesting huh yeah I
converted to Islam
instead of being 2009 in Cairo Egypt so
how is it slum there and Tolan is it
because I know they try to suppress I
don't live in Poland I live in England
but I don't think there is any I didn't
have to be I just decided to make my
wife we decided to leave outside because
no yeah so we decided to live somewhere
else anyway mhm
and having recently because me have a
problem my family because of this
obviously visited my uncle recently and
is the friction because of this because
the Catholic you know background and
family and because of my belief in Islam
is relation is was gone the ties are cut
Allah make it easy yeah I remember when
when I became Muslim I was like 10 years
ago I used to watch you program a lot
and I think it's one of the best yeah
because you're really like you touch
even Islam like in a soft way not like
you know like extreme or like the
radical is and it's not and then you you
convey the message in a nice way
like watching it and thinking like you
know this is the way you should you know
have like have a proper Islamic program
just you know with like this kind of
attitude you know relax you know know
like because there's many guys out there
they have programs like shouting
screaming bit like very hardcore you
know they want to make make everything
extreme and it's just not the way I
think and it won't bring people to Islam
this attitude but your attitude is great
if I was watching if I was looking for
Islam or get trying to get close to this
Lama I see I come across the program
notice the Muslim before it's definitely
a good big like a good first step you
know people from coming to the house
exactly this is wrong this is wrong and
then I ask the guy are you Muslim the
guy who wants to charge me money said
I'm not Muslim I said we're done you
looking after math you're not Muslim any
forbidding Muslim to go to the Masjid
this is even more wrong because he was a
Muslim then it's like MEC says he's
looking after the place but he's not
Muslim charging the tickets Muslims to
go in and yeah but I saw people praying
outside I know if you want to make it to
a few extra rocker or if you miss the
prayer you can make it outside but I saw
the tour is going in and out yeah so why
would you stop a Muslim to go and this
is wrong yet it's nice to meet people
from all over and we just met a brother
from Poland and just like everywhere
else you know you say it's the free
world and
freedom to practice what you believe but
you can see they trying to suppress the
way of God Almighty Islam in different
parts especially Poland Poland what's
going on
that's Amash you guys gotta let the
people free the people to go ahead and
worship the one guy but what same way
Jesus worship well you guys scared up